ce qu'on voit sur la police à la
télévision
70% de communication 30% de la formation
il y a de l'action il y a de l'émotion
et il y a de l'information et quand
reportage sur les unités des lits son
donuts entre la télévision et la police
elle-même
le journaliste qui cultivait leur
relation avec la publicité ça peut
donner le meilleur ou le pire et les
journalistes ils ont besoin de la police
pour faire des images donc on va pas
cogner sur un flic que tu auras besoin
de recontacter le lendemain dans notre
police nationale il n'est jamais très
bon de trop parler la police est
transparente j'espère en tout cas c'est
dans le sens que nous travaillons pour
les secours
les séries de police scientifiques sont
très rarement réalistes comme nous
intervenons sur une scène de crime ce
n'est pas un talon aiguille
mon dieu mais c'est bien sûr
[Musique]
après les séries et les reportages sur
les forces de l'ordre qui fleurissent à
la télévision depuis des années un
nouveau genre d'émission a vu le jour
mais 2010 France Télévisions consacre un
programme de deux heures en prime time à
la gendarmerie une soirée à la gloire
des forces de l'ordre
c'est l'animateur vedette de la chaîne
Michel Drucker qui officie les peoples
sont de la partie Véronique Genest
allias Julie Lescaut et Corinne Touzel à
super gendarmettes et on guest star
Denis Favier le patron du GIGN le groupe
d'élite de la gendarmerie
pour Dominique Rizet spécialiste de la
police au Figaro Magazine et
chroniqueurs sur France 2 la gendarmerie
n'a pas sa place dans ce type de show
cette émission c'est un défilé du 14
juillet c'est un peu ça quoi voilà mais
bien en rond les montres on met devant
Favier patron du GIGN qui a franchement
autre chose à faire autre chose à faire
de son temps de faire des trucs pareils
quoi alors publie reportage ou
information en tout cas la gendarmerie à
co-financer le programme à hauteur de
350 000 euros
le monde des médias s'en était mu mais
pour le GIGN il n'y a aucune controverse
cette affaire d'un appel vraiment aucune
polémique
les missions
mon goût de porter générale grand public
avec des artistes des journalistes moi
je trouve ça très très bon j'en suis pas
choqué
non c'est pas le terme on a pris
beaucoup de sérieux mais j'ai trouvé
j'ai trouvé bien et puis et puis c'est
bien de se présenter tel qu'on est à nos
concitoyens
la gendarmerie s'est offert ni vu ni
connu un super coup de pub et la chaîne
a attiré 3 millions et demi de personnes
les forces de l'ordre et la télévision
c'est une vieille histoire d'amour
le policier télégénique il fascine les
téléspectateurs et fait de l'audimat
le ministère de l'Intérieur accorde
chaque année des centaines
d'autorisations à des journalistes pour
qu'ils filment leurs hommes mais la
police s'autorise-t-elle pour autant les
médias à introduire leur caméra partout
ils le souhaitent quelle police
montre-t-on au téléspectateurs que leur
cachetons
l'image est-elle conforme à la réalité
et quels sont les enjeux politiques de
la police à la télévision
[Musique]
4 3 bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur le
plateau des cinq dernières minutes nous
sommes pas sur un vrai plateau télé mais
à l'école des commissaires de police
pour la région Nanterre bonjour Monsieur
le Commissaire alors
il reçoit un média training une
formation pour être à l'aise devant une
caméra quand on est cadre dans la police
on n'a pas le droit de dire n'importe
quoi est-ce considérable du nombre de
blessés et de morts sur les routes cette
simulation est animée par un autre
commissaire et surtout par une
journaliste de télévision dont vous ne
verrez pas le visage elle souhaite
garder l'anonymat pour que sa rédaction
ne sache pas qu'elle travaille avec la
police cette formation reste assez
conventionnelle la journaliste nommait
pas le commissaire en difficulté comme
il pourrait l'être sur un vrai plateau
télé
quelle mesure allez vous prendre concret
pour que enfin cela cesse du coup
l'apprenti communicant répète des
phrases toutes faites effectivement la
lutte contre l'insécurité routière c'est
une des priorités gouvernementales et
cela depuis plusieurs années pourtant
l'image de la police est un enjeu
hautement stratégique pour le pouvoir en
place
nous sommes dans une administration très
hiérarchisée donc certaines situations
ont un enjeu ou une un questionnement
d'ordre politique et c'est vrai que la
communication peut venir brouiller le
champ ou le message politique et donc
c'est une communication à risque un
exercice à risque pour ces hommes et ces
femmes ce sont des policiers pas des
bêtes de scène alors on essaye de les
préparer au mieux
un peu impressionnant voilà parce qu'en
fait on n'a pas l'habitude et c'est un
peu cette habitude qu'on vient chercher
donc lors du stage on est de plus en
plus sollicité que ce soit par les
chaînes télévisées par la radio par la
presse écrite et chaîne nationale ou
régionale parce que la police a
intéresse tout le monde si vous enlevez
les feuilles tombent policiers et vous
avez plus rien à la télé
les commissaires sont de plus en plus
réclamés par les médias mais on les voit
encore peu dans le journal télévisé
faute d'autorisation de leur hiérarchie
qui reste frileuse pourtant ça n'a pas
toujours été le cas
[Musique]
pendant longtemps ils ont été les
vedettes du petit écran et 100 médias
training c'était les années 70 l'époque
des prises de tâches des superflics et
des ennemis publics le premier qui a
capté l'oeil des caméras c'est le
commissaire Broussard alors chef de
l'antigang devenu célèbre pour avoir mis
fin à la cavale de Jacques Mesrine
15h15 cet après-midi Porte de
Clignancourt à Paris au milieu de la
circulation une fusillade éclate une
voiture grise s'immobilise criblée de
balle à l'intérieur tu es nette chaque
Mesrine
tout à l'heure tout à l'heure
devant les caméras juste après avoir
fait tomber Mesrine son meilleur ennemi
et ses temps ensemble qu'ils sont entrés
dans la légende
un ennemi public numéro 1 se fabrique
une image c'est en bambeletor ça on est
le meilleur on est le plus grand n'est
plus fort et bon et il est évident que
on veut en face de soi
un policier à la hauteur le drame pour
un ennemi public numéro 1 c'est c'est
d'être arrêté par un gardien de la paix
au coin d'une rue parce qu'il a pas
accroché sa ceinture vous voyez le flic
et le voyou c'était bien trouvé des
bêtes de scène c'est de là du coup
Broussard devient la coqueluche des
médias une aubaine pour sa hiérarchie
avec son style décontracté il donne
l'image d'un flic tout-terrain qui parle
devant la caméra où il veut quand il
veut mais ces prises de parole sont en
fait très encadrées toute façon à chaque
fois ça se passait avec le feu vert de
la direction veut voir de la justice et
du ministère il est il était hors de
question d'aller sur un plateau de télé
sans avoir le feu vert mais bien souvent
c'était l'inverse qui se passait en vous
demandez de d'aller c'était des séances
qui étaient quand même très pénibles
pour moi très très pénible pourquoi
parce que j'étais pas à l'aise tout
simplement
bref j'avais une appréhension j'avais
toujours la peur de de dire un mot de
travail
d'aller trop loin pas assez loin c'est
pas facile quand vous débutez surtout
dans des affaires extrêmement délicates
c'était parce que plus difficile sur le
plateau de télé que je me demande
d'intervention
Broussard super star c'était une autre
époque
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on ne voit plus de grandes figures de
flic à la télévision la police est
devenue désincarnée avec des hommes qui
n'ont même parfois ni non ni visage
avril 2010 c'est sur Home masqué ce sont
les policiers du Raid ok les gars ça
commence la fouille des lieux l'unité
d'élite de la police créée en 1985 par
le commissaire Broussard
ce jour-là il s'entraîne et se prête au
jeu de notre caméra des images que l'on
a vu des dizaines de fois dans des
reportages
derrière c'était bien ça s'est bien
organisé l'éclatement c'était STB avait
une difficulté en fait il fallait
éclater sur sur trois pièces différentes
je fais du trouver ça j'ai trouvé ça
assez fluide vous avez rencontré des
difficultés particulières
tout est fait pour impressionner les
flingues l'uniforme la cagoule le raid
c'est moins de 200 hommes
une goutte d'eau parmi les 150 000
policiers français mais le ministère de
l'Intérieur aime vendre au journaliste
cette vitrine celle d'une police qui
impressionne et qui rassure on voit
toujours oui le côté super-héros à la
télé mais je pense que c'est ce qui fait
aussi c'est ce qui plaît aux gens quoi
souvent c'est impossible et sur la
cagoule l'intervention la porte
l'explosion les médias vous cherchez
l'audience donc l'audience vous savez
comment la récupérer quoi
Christophe Labé journaliste au Point et
réalisateur de documentaires a mené une
enquête approfondie sur la police dans
son livre place Beauvau
pour lui c'est flics musclés c'est le
dimat assuré quand on a créé ces unités
on a essayé aussi on a travaillé sur
l'image de ces unités donc dès le départ
on a
vendu l'image de super-héros et quand
vous avez des gens et c'est vrai qui
prennent des risques pour des
interventions
effectivement vous vous avez des gens
qui sortent de l'ordinaire et donc qui
sont qui intéressent forcément
ces hommes du Raid sollicité pour les
opérations les plus périlleuses
fascinent les spectateurs qui en
prennent plein la vue
du coup l'unité est assailli par les
journalistes il y a une ou plusieurs
équipes de journalistes en permanence
qui suit leur aide sur les thématiques
différentes que ce soit négociations que
ce soit l'émission de formation
étrangers une émission de protection de
nos ambassadeurs
l'émission d'intervention on a toujours
une équipe de journalistes mon problème
à moi c'est d'établir une chaîne de
liste d'attentes les hommes en cagoule
sont aujourd'hui des stars des médias on
annonce bien tous les individus mais ça
n'a pas toujours été le cas contact s'il
y a besoin à la création de l'unité il y
avait même un blackout total sur ces
policiers sans visage c'est un événement
singulier qui va mettre ce corps d'élite
sur le devant de la scène allez on y va
nous sommes en mai 1993
fin du cauchemar pour les six enfants et
leur maîtresses retenus en otage pendant
46 heures à Neuilly-sur-Seine libéré à
7h25 ce matin par les policiers du Raid
qui ont tué le preneur d'otage
un homme qui se fait appeler human bombe
muni d'explosifs prend en otage une
classe d'une maternelle de Neuilly et
menace de tout faire sauter pendant 2
jours les journalistes campent devant
l'école et les Français sont scotché
devant leur écran
finalement le preneur d'otage est abattu
par le Raid et les enfants sortent sain
et sauf un peu dur le Premier ministre
les hommes de l'unité apparaissent alors
comme des sauveurs une opportunité pour
les politiques de l'époque pour Charles
Pasqua alors ministre de l'Intérieur
et pour Nicolas Sarkozy alors maire de
Neuilly est déjà ministre
on envoyait procureur de la République
qui a été très couragés qui a négocié
lui-même parce que moi il ne voulait
plus me voir il voulait plus parler il
disait que je l'avais trahi et donc le
procureur négocié le préfet a été
formidable les gens du RAID ont été
extraordinaires un de ces hommes c'est
Daniel Boulanger c'est lui qui a tué le
preneur d'otage il a été recruté par
broutsard et la création du raid et y a
passé 20 ans on a été mieux connu je
dirais de peut-être sur le plan national
mais également international puisque
cette affaire a été connu dans le monde
entier donc effectivement ça apportait
une réputation de d'efficacité au
service
donc j'espère que que ce genre de
situation et d'événements après peu
dissuader d'éventuelles preneurs de
tâches de ne pas de ne pas commettre
d'autres méfaits du même style le raid
utilise donc les médias pour
impressionner les gangsters il peut même
aller encore plus loin dans
l'utilisation de la télévision comme une
arme contre des venduesles agresseurs on
fait semblant de montrer des choses
qu'on a pas par exemple ce qui peut
inquiéter éventuellement nos
d'éventuelles adversaires en leur
faisant croire qu'on a un matériel
hyper-sophistiqué
qui peut donc leur faire croire que on
verra à travers les murs et on entendra
tout ce qui se passe ou bien alors on
montre carrément qu'on n'a pas ce
matériel alors qu'on l'a si vous voulez
donc on peut on peut jouer
l'intox
après c'est le spectateur qui va faire
sa propre sa propre analyse en quelque
sorte en livrant du spectaculaire clé en
main le raid manipule les médias et les
journalistes ne cherchent pas à en
savoir plus
[Musique]
après Neuilly un autre événement met un
autre corps d'élite sur le devant de la
scène il s'agissait des super gendarmes
du GIGN
il était 17h12 quand les gendarmes du
GIGN ont donné l'assaut à l'Airbus d'Air
France dont des terroristes islamiques
Algériens avaient pris le contrôle
depuis samedi l'assaut donnée par les
gendarmes du GIGN a été remarquablement
exécuté puisqu'il n'y a pas eu de mort
ni même de blesser très grave parmi les
passagers et les membres de l'équipage
les Français assistent en quasi direct à
la plus importante libération d'otages
jamais réalisée à bord d'un avion pour
Dominique Rizet c'est grâce à ces images
saisissantes que les hommes du GIGN sont
devenus les héros de la nation et des
vedettes des médias l'élément fondateur
de la médiatisation du GIGN c'est
l'affaire de Marignane pourquoi parce
que jusqu'ici cette unité qui appartient
à l'armée était une unité dont on
parlait pas
la grande muette l'armée au communique
pas et à partir de là ça a été tellement
incroyable et inattendu qu'on puisse
sauver tous les passagers de l'avion en
neutralisant les preneurs d'otages
tellement bluffant pour la direction de
la gendarmerie elle-même qu'à partir de
là ils sont dit mais c'est incroyable le
le l'impact que ça sur nous sur notre
notre institution gendarmestre qui se
sont dit ok on va en parler on va s'en
servir on va servir du GIGN parce que
maintenant c'est un tel bon produit
qu'on va le vendre et le promouvoir dans
le monde entier le retour des héros il
était un peu plus de deux heures ce
matin quand l'avion transportant une
partie des otages et les gendarmes du
GIGN c'est posé à Orly accompagné du
ministre de la Défense les gendarmes
d'élite sont sortis sous les
applaudissements des familles de ceux
qu'ils avaient sauvés reçu à l'Élysée
les gendarmes sont annulés ils
deviennent les chouchous des médias 16
ans après ces images le général Denis
Favier qui avait mené l'assaut condamne
pourtant la diffusion en quasi direct de
l'intervention la diffusion même en
léger différée des images de la Sao ont
occasionné chez nous et au-delà de
l'unité un réel traumatisme ce sont des
images qu'on est allé chercher il était
peut-être pas opportun de vous montrer
certes cette opération c'est un succès
et on montre l'image du GIGN à l'assaut
dans une démarche offensive qui débouche
sur une réussite opérationnelle et ça
nous positionne mais à l'inverse si
l'affaire avait été un échec les mêmes
images elle nous aurait condamné alors
qu'on aurait eu la même action avec le
même courage le même abnégation et ça
serait posé un vrai un vrai problème
mais l'asso a été une réussite alors
depuis les télévisions s'arrachent le
GIGN qui désormais contrôle parfaitement
sa communication
avril 2010 opération séduction GIGN
l'unité inaugure de nouveaux locaux
c'est le SIRPA le service de relation
publique des armées qui organise la
manifestation le GIGN aujourd'hui c'est
380 personnels ils sont tous là le
ministre de l'Intérieur je vais derrière
lui
et les journalistes spécialisés venus en
nombre Dominique riset et de la partie
un peu agacée par la bousculade
je vous explique
et si on ne ramène par là
je t'habilles correctement on peut
attraper le général qui s'occupe de la
pomme manifestement le patron de la
communication et les journalistes se
connaissent bien au contraire tu es
accueilli dans le sein des saints de la
gendarmerie viens l'heure de la
démonstration pour les hommes du GIGN
qui exhibent leur artillerie
c'est un vrai moi je vais chez moi
mais les vrais techniques de l'unité
aucune caméra n'a le droit d'aller voir
alors on voit énormément de choses mais
on ne voit pas tout on ne voit pas tout
c'est-à-dire quand est-ce qu'on voit si
vous voulez ce sont des choses qui quand
même globalement sont des choses qui ont
déjà été déjà été abordés auparavant
dans les médias c'est à dire qu'il y a
aucun moment si vous voulez on aborde
des choses qui doivent être tenues
encore aujourd'hui de manière
confidentielle après les unités d'élite
les journalistes tomber leur caméra sur
d'autres flics
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ce sont les policiers de la BAC la
brigade anti criminalité créée en 1994
ils incarnent des professionnels d'un
genre nouveau look tout terrain Jean et
blouson de cuir voiture banalisée ce
sont des policiers qui nous ressemblent
la BAC devient le service à la mode le
ministère veut les médiatiser et les
journalistes en sont friands
ces images tournées en 1995 pour Zone
Interdite sont celles de philippe poiret
l'un des premiers à leur avoir consacré
un reportage à l'époque le le flic en
civil le flic de la BAC était assez
était légionné quoi ça c'est sûr on
aimait bien son histoire il avait une
bonne gueule donc ça passait bien
évidemment pour le ministère intérieur
c'était c'était bon
restez bien simple c'était fini Pineau
simple fille qui avait plus de siffler
il y a plus de bâtons et puis de képi là
on prenait le même mec mais on l'habille
en civil et bien souvent c'était des
jeunes mecs assez athlétique donc vous
avez des bonnes gueule des bonnes
tronches ils avaient des langages codés
ça parlait je me rappelle très très bien
dans des talkie-walkie sans envoyer le
bois c'est à dire que les pneus Christ
c'est
donc c'était à mon avis pour quelqu'un
qui aurait écrit une fission c'était le
bonheur
Raoul et Hakim c'est un peu les Starsky
et Hutch marseillais il ressemble plus
au voyou que leur collègue en uniforme
et on est bien loin du flic à la papas
dans un commissariat ils sont ancrés
dans les préoccupations des Français
l'insécurité et la drogue
[Musique]
Violaine Laborde et psychologues à
l'école de police l'institution
réfléchie à l'image que véhicules ces
hommes de la BAC
la trait du policier en civile par
rapport aux policiers en tenue je crois
que c'est
le policier qui n'est pas peut-être dans
la militarité alors le policier en tenue
c'est effectivement celui qui oublie aux
ordres alors que le policier en civile
est perçu je pense dans l'imaginaire
dans les représentations comme quelqu'un
qui a beaucoup plus de latitude comme
quelqu'un qui est beaucoup plus maître
de son enquête
qui essaye aussi de se fondre dans la
population pour essayer d'investiguer
il y a combien de watts là-dedans
[Musique]
avec les reportages sur la BAC et les
Français découvrent la banlieue mais les
années 2000 passent par là avec leur lot
de violence et l'étoile médiatique de la
BAC va pas lire
en 1994 quand on voulait traiter la
banlieue
le plus simple c'était celui d'une
équipe de la BAC là on pénétrait la
banlieue on allait dans des zones dites
de l'endroit etc envoyer du trafic de
stup on voyait même un petit peu des
armes qui circulaient etc au jour
d'aujourd'hui c'est pas possible vous
suivez pas une équipe de la BAC
parce qu'elle rentrera pas dans les
mêmes ça je suis à peu près persuadé je
suis sûr que on fait une dizaine
d'années après le même le même reportage
il est impossible à Marseille je suis à
peu près persuadé de ça voilà donc
la gueule je suis sûr je suis sûr que
ces gens-là il rentre pas il rentre pas
si on fait backbevu je pense qu'il y a
un impact quand même et bavure je pense
qu'un bon paquet de bavure mais voilà ça
ça n'engage que moi mais
[Musique]
non
mal aimé des citoyens peut-être mais la
police sur le petit écran c'est toujours
bon pour le dimanche
un homme de média exploite le filon des
unités musclées c'est Charles Villeneuve
avec son émission le droit de savoir
diffusé sur TF1 dès 1990
pendant 18 ans ses équipes filent en
immersion des flics des stups du raid ou
de la baraque le succès est immédiat et
Charles Villeneuve devient le parrain de
la police à la télé
[Musique]
dans un magazine concernant la police la
gendarmerie ou les groupes d'actions que
ce soit le GIGN ce soir red que ce soit
d'autre services c'est des personnages
et une histoire donc la mode de bon elle
fluctue de toute façon lorsque vous avez
un service d'action
plus une histoire c'est à dire une
enquête
le début et la fin d'une enquête plus
les personnages vous avez un reportage
réussi obligatoirement parce que vous
avez l'action vous avez l'émotion et
vous savez l'information
Charleville neuve a été critiqué dans la
presse pour avoir fait de la police le
fond de commerce de ses émissions
jusqu'à être accusé de faire de la télé
gyrophare
je crois pas qu'on faisait l'apologie de
la police pas du tout ont montré une
réalité cette réalité et bien les
journalistes qui sont pas trop bêtes
l'exploitent alors évidemment après on
va mettre si vous voulez tout un tout un
système de correctif sur le plan de
l'éthique sur le plan de la morale avec
beaucoup d'hypocrisies d'ailleurs
beaucoup d'hypocrisie et notamment de la
presse de la part de la presse écrite
qui ne cesse d'attaquer les journalistes
de télévision par rapport à ces
productions là parce qu'ils sont
incapables eux de restituer cette action
cette émotion cette information aussi
instantanée dans l'esprit public
des téléspectateurs ou des spectateurs
ceux qui vont au cinéma sur les
reportages de ce qu'on appelle la
gyrophare
la télé qui va
obtenir un centre d'autorisation et
montrer des scènes spectaculaires sans
enquêter vraiment sur la réalité de la
police se contenter de spectaculaires
qui vont faire de l'audimat
sur ces reportages et des phénomènes de
mode il est phénomènes de mode il
dépendent de quoi et ben ils dépendent
tout simplement de l'efficacité des
différents services avant de
leur image
[Musique]
et téléspectateurs raffolent des
reportages sur les unités d'action
celles qui font rêver mais la véritable
usine enfantasme ce sont les fictions
policières en France et le fond d'un
carton depuis 50 ans en assurant aux
chaînes leur meilleures audiences
pour Pierre l'anglais journaliste
spécialisé dans les séries pas étonnant
que le genre policier passionne depuis
si longtemps la série policière a
toujours été très présente depuis les
années 50 jusqu'à aujourd'hui parce que
c'est un genre qui se prête à
l'observation de la société à la
discussion de thème fort évidemment à
l'observation aussi des côtés les plus
sombres de la société donc ils sont
toujours un peu fascinants les flics
eux-mêmes sont des personnages
fascinants on rêve un petit peu le
métier on sait pas trop et donc voilà
pourquoi le genre policier aussi prisé
parce que il crée un vrai réceptacle un
réceptacle très intéressant à la société
et à toutes nos fascinations
si les flics de fiction fascinent autant
c'est parce que les auteurs ont fondé
héros bien loin de la réalité
une réalité que Simon Michael et
Philippe bizarre ont bien connu ils sont
scénaristes mais surtout anciens flic
tout de tracket proxénète et gangster
j'adore
qui centrait tu vois
au milieu du verre Simon Michael est le
scénariste des ripoux et de la série
flic sur TF1 pour faire du flic grand
public pas question de montrer le vrai
visage de la police pas assez sexy les
flics c'est des milliers d'heures
d'attente de merde dans des bureaux de
merde pour vivre un instant de truc
c'est quoi la vie d'un flic 98% des
flics de sortiront jamais leur arme et
certains même pas au stand de tir
on prend forcément on décrire que des
moments extrêmes d'une vie et des
situations extrêmes qui sont les crimes
de sang des choses comme ça donc c'est
forcément décalé par rapport à la
réalité le vécu n'est pas un garanti de
cinégénie n'est pas une garantie de
crédibilité et de dramaturgie ça fait un
demi-siècle que les scénaristes créent
des figures de flics télégéniques
passage en revue des troupes
le premier a déclencher les hostilités
c'est le Commissaire Bourrel dans les
cinq dernières minutes
[Musique]
mon dieu mais c'est bien sûr
il incarne le policier de la France
profonde Un héros très ordinaire tout
comme le commissaire Maigret 10 ans plus
tard
les années 70 c'est l'irruption des
séries américaines et ses flics jeunes
et décontracté
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les années 80 à 2000 voix fleurir des
policiers consensuels avec Navarro et
Julie Lescaut une commissaire mère de
famille qui a tout pour plaire à la
ménagère de moins de 50 ans
[Musique]
2010 la mode est aux anti-héros à la
Braquo et surtout aux flics en blouse
blanche qui explose tous les records de
diamants
[Musique]
loin de Miami et Las Vegas nous avons
rencontré les vrais experts ceux de la
gendarmerie scientifique en banlieue
parisienne
[Musique]
moins high tech et moins glamour que
dans les séries mais ces experts là sont
mondialement reconnus comme dans la
série Boons ils font parler les
ossements des victimes
[Musique]
les experts ne vont pas sur le terrain
faire procéder à des actes d'enquête
on procède pas non plus à des
interrogatoires
nous l'intervenons encore rarement sur
le terrain
auprès des enquêteurs pour une
interpellation et en tout cas pas avec
pistolet au point comme n'importe quelle
enquêteur
il est très rare en tout cas pas de
notre côté quand nous intervenons sur
une scène de crime ce n'est pas un talon
aiguille
après les vrais Bones de la gendarmerie
voici les vrais experts de la police
nationale
[Musique]
Anne travaille en section biologique ici
on analyse des traces de sang de sperme
ou de salive sur les pièces à conviction
cette technicienne bondit devant son
écran quand elle voit les hérésies
scientifiques
[Musique]
dans les séries télé en fait il faut que
ça soit visuellement joli ici le plus
important c'est de ne pas contaminer
dans le cas des experts on est sûr de
retrouver leur profil génétique en
mélange avec les traces
qui sont en train d'effectuer c'est
impossible puisqu'ils n'ont pas de
masque donc sans masque forcément comme
il parle dans les dans les séries qui
parlent donc ils contamine le
prélèvement qu'ils ont devant eux c'est
obligatoire
dans les séries on s'arrange avec la
réalité mais on révèle quand même
d'authentiques techniques et les
criminels eux aussi regardent la
télévision
[Musique]
dans les séries télé il montre
énormément de choses et ça donne des
idées au criminel et surtout ça leur
apprend à mieux se protéger pour les
affaires de viol c'est pareil il y avait
très rarement l'utilisation de
préservatif maintenant oui
les experts de fiction sont des
super-héros qui trouvent des réponses à
tout et très vite du coup il suscite des
attentes irréalistes chez certaines
victimes
on a la crédibilité qui est mise en
doute et surtout la croyance que l'on
peut résoudre une affaire en 40 minutes
ça c'est quelque chose de terrible que
je rencontrer régulièrement notamment
dans le cadre des de l'identification
des victimes de catastrophe ou plus de 1
mois après la catastrophe on a des
réunions avec les familles avec les
autorités politiques et judiciaires et
on est pris à partie systématiquement
par les familles en disant on ne
comprend pas que au 21e siècle un mois
après la catastrophe on n'est pas encore
identifié nos proches pour qu'on puisse
commencer notre deuil et faire et ça
c'est une des conséquences de du
silessaie effect dire que le temps du
médiatique n'est pas le temps de
scientifiques
et après une décennie de héros
scientifique voici venu le temps du
policier psychologue la grosse mode du
moment en termes de série policière
c'est le retour du héros c'est le
mentaliste c'est Lie to Me c'est de la
série où on a un personnage unique fort
qui a été influencé par docteur House
bizarrement qui est aussi une sorte de
flic mais pour les virus et du coup la
grosse tendance qui est encore très
forte qui est celle des flics
scientifiques et un peu en train de
baisser mais toujours là donc on va dire
qu'en gros on a une confrontation entre
ces deux grosses tendances-là le flic un
petit peu spécial qui peut lire un peu
dans les pensées et le flic
scientifiques qui est lui est un
cartésien pur et dur et qui suit la
science et qui va droit au but
[Musique]
retour à la réalité ou parfois là aussi
il y a de la mise en scène le ministère
de l'Intérieur utilise certaines
opérations de police pour en faire du
spectacle avec manipulation des
journalistes à la clé
novembre 2016 après le décès de deux
jeunes dans une collision entre leur
moto et une voiture de police des
émeutes éclatent à Villiers-le-Bel des
dizaines de policiers sont blessés
certains se font tirer dessus à balles
réelles
[Musique]
trois mois plus tard mille policiers
font une descente dans une cité encore
endormie de Villiers-le-Bel pour arrêter
les jeunes à l'origine des échauffourés
un dispositif impressionnant la police
veut frapper un grand coup
cette opération sensible supposée être
discrète et couverte par de nombreux
journalistes
qui à médiatisé cette affaire et
pourquoi les journalistes ont-ils été
manipulés Laurent Richard journaliste de
l'agence Capa était présent ce jour-là
c'est un vendredi soir là j'avais 13 à
peine en absence et deux SMS c'était un
policier il m'a dit faut que je te parle
d'une arrestation qui va avoir lieu il
faut qu'on se voit très rapidement c'est
du Off de chez off j'apparais pas c'est
pas moi qui te le dis tu es le seul à le
savoir ah bon tu es sûr je suis le seul
tu es le seul à le savoir et voyons-nous
très vite et c'est comme ça que trois
jours plus tard je me suis retrouvé
pensant être le seul et là on a vu des
dizaines de journalistes sortir d'une
poubelle sortir de derrière un buisson
derrière une voiture en fait en gros il
y avait toute la presse française qui
était là et un procureur aussi qui
arrivait enfin tout était écrit à
l'avance pour que on soit là et pour que
tout le monde soit là et pour que ça
passe à la télévision le soir maintenant
bonjour vous êtes qui vous bonjour
agence CAPA est-ce que vous pouvez me
rassembler les journalistes
je veux bien faire une déclaration mais
je voudrais que les journées soient
rassemblées
à voir quoi on sait même complètement
fait avoir parce que c'était personne
n'était informé exclusivement de ça
parce que il y avait un vrai souci de la
part de qui je ne sais pas mais en tout
cas il y a une vraie une vraie un vrai
souci de communiquer de rassembler les
journalistes sans que ça se sache
sans que ça paraisse mais là c'était
trop gros pour pas que ça se voit quoi
vous êtes qui vous
êtes le président
immédiatement et il est à ce moment-là à
6h30 ou 7h ou 7h30 du matin donc elle
est venue pour ça ils peuvent pas dire
on voulait pas médiatiser ça et en même
temps demander à la procureur d'être là
de communiquer tout ça
voilà on se fait manipuler du début
jusqu'à la fin dans cette histoire on
est absolument tous au courant moi
j'avais même récupéré avant la descente
un document de la police avec les noms
des cibles
des types qui allait être interpellés
j'avais le document à la veille le
dimanche ça m'est jamais arrivé de
nombreux journalistes étaient donc
présents ce matin au moment des
interpellations une médiatisation qui a
provoqué de nombreuses réactions au sein
de la classe politique certains évoquent
une mise en scène trois semaines avant
le premier tour des élections en
municipales qui a tiré les ficelles de
ce cirque médiatique certains ont pointé
du doigt la Place Beauvau qui aurait
voulu exhiber son efficacité en période
électorale la ministre de l'Intérieur de
l'époque c'était pourtant officiellement
offusqué de cette médiatisation cette
médiatisation pouvait avoir des
conséquences graves sur l'opération le
ministère intérieur a dit qu'il n'avait
pas communiqué
en fait il y a une hypocrisie
certes parfois le ministère intérieur
veut vendre ses opérations et comme il
peut pas le faire directement c'est
compliqué
il délègue ce travail au syndicat
qui des syndicats de police ou de la
place Bovo ont prévenu les journalistes
nul n'aura le fin mot de cette histoire
politique au médiatique en tout cas ce
matin-là 33 personnes sont arrêtées
devant des caméras de télévisions cet
épisode met en lumière le rapport de
force entre deux pouvoirs celui de la
police et celui des médias
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
dans une société sous tension dans
laquelle l'insécurité est un thème
récurrent l'image des forces de l'ordre
doit être irréprochable en 2006 Nicolas
Sarkozy alors ministre de l'Intérieur
crée le service communication de la
police nationale
objectif du service réagir devant les
médias en cas de crise et faire la promo
de l'institution auprès de la population
Pierre Joxe ministre de l'intérieur sous
François Mitterrand dans les années 80
critique la communication à outrance
je vais vous décevoir je n'ai jamais eu
de stratégie de communication je
considère que ce complètement bidon ce
qui compte la vie politique c'est ce
qu'on fait c'est parce qu'on raconte par
conséquent
je répondais au journaliste qui faisait
leur métier et moi je faisais mon métier
qui était de travailler de j'ai fait un
centre de choses qui sont restés connues
d'ailleurs en matière de modernisation
de la police de formation des personnels
de police on n'a pas besoin de stratégie
de communication quand on fait des
choses utiles et réussir
ces trois journalistes connaissent bien
l'univers de la police
pierre Baretti monsieur flic de TF1
Stéphane bentura grand reporter et
Patricia tout Ranchot du journal
Libération et réalisatrice de
documentaires
aujourd'hui
tout le monde fait du fait divers et des
questions de police donc la police a dû
s'adapter avec la gendarmerie donc ils
ont des services de communication donc
c'est pas de l'information qu'on a c'est
de la com qu'on offre aux journalistes
alors journaliste de savoir si c'est une
com qui est intéressante qui va pouvoir
se rattacher à un fait d'actualité à eux
de savoir l'utiliser ou bien eux de
de la vallée ce Sarkozy
depuis 2002 en fait le ministère de
l'Intérieur a décidé de reprendre un mal
à la communication parce que sinon
c'était les syndicats de police qui
parlaient en off journaliste ou en on et
il y avait jamais la parole de
l'administration donc il a mis en place
il a étoffé son service de communication
ministère de l'Intérieur le cycoop qui
s'occupe c'est le service de com de la
direction générale de la police
nationale il a mis beaucoup plus de
d'officiers de com à travailler dedans
contrôler les contenus parce que la
police est un enjeu politique c'est pas
simplement la police qui veut son image
pour elle-même c'est son image pour la
politique gouvernementale sécuritaire
Catherine hachewer c'est directrice de
la communication de la police nationale
et flics de haut niveau un poste
stratégique elle ne prend jamais la
parole devant les médias elle a
exceptionnellement accepté d'être
interviewé après quatre mois de
réflexion
[Musique]
nous ne cherchons pas à donner des
choses lisses ni à comment dirais-je
à distiller une image
quelconque on cherchait à être
transparent il y a montré le mieux
possible en un temps souvent court parce
que
vos sujets ne durent pas non plus des
heures et dans le temps que vous avez
pour illustrer un sujet nous cherchons à
vous aider à illustrer du mieux possible
la réalité de des missions
malgré les propos de Catherine ashwers
il reste difficile de décrocher des
interviews de policiers quand une chaîne
a besoin du témoignage de l'un d'entre
eux pour la grand-messe du 20h ou pour
un débat le plus souvent elle n'appelle
pas le service communication mais pas
directement par les syndicalistes qui
s'expriment eux sans autorisation
Yannick d'agneau est l'un de ses
délégués syndicaux ce jour-là il est
invité à LCI pour parler sécurité je
pense que la politique de sécurité est
menée largement en France depuis 2002
avec des hauts et des bas on va dire
qu'actuellement nous sommes plutôt dans
une période de bas les syndicats ont la
part belle à la télévision car les
policiers sont tenus au devoir de
réserve sans autorisation express de
leur hiérarchie il reste muet
quand les policiers disent comme mes
collègues disent devant une caméra
nous on vit on est quelque part les
éboueurs de notre société on doit
traiter ce dont personne ne veut
personne ne veut plus personne ne veut
parler
le garde d'un appel qui dit ça devant
une caméra sans avoir une couverture
syndicale il va passer en conseil de
discipline
Bénédicte des Forges fonctionnaire de
police en disponibilité et d'une
exception elle a pris la plume pour
raconter le quotidien et les difficultés
de sa profession
moi si je vous dis que la politique du
résultat c'est une fainé à faire j'ai
pas l'impression de d'enfreindre la
l'obligation de réserve je le dis je
pense que 99,9% des flics pensent comme
moi
mais ne le disent pas
à force de rabâcher cette histoire
d'obligation de réserve on finit par
perdre un peu la limite qui a entre
elle et la liberté d'opinion donc
effectivement il y a beaucoup de gens
qui sont un peu
frileux avec l'expression libre on va
dire
[Applaudissements]
sans la bénédiction de leur hiérarchie
les policiers ne parlent pas leur rares
discours sont très policés difficiles
alors pour les journalistes de
télévision de mener de vrais enquêtes la
télévision a du mal à sortir des infos
un peu dérangeantes sur la police parce
que il faut des images il faudrait
qu'elle est un policier qui se pose
devant la caméra comme je suis devant la
caméra et qui disent oui nous trafiquons
les chiffres de la délinquance oui ça va
nous le faisons
oui nous contrôlons faciès c'est vrai
nous le faisons et ça c'est absolument
impossible impossible d'obtenir de la
police des témoignages critiques la
Direction de la Communication reconnaît
qu'elle n'a pas vocation à ouvrir toutes
les portes
je dis à mes à mes collègues lorsqu'ils
sont sollicités pour accueillir des
journalistes dans leur service que
il faut qu'il s'imagine dans la même
situation que lorsqu'ils invitent des
amis chez eux quand on a envie des amis
chez nous
en nous tous nous les accueillons dans
la salle à manger dans le salon la
limite dans la cuisine
voilà donc nous leur montrons le
meilleur le meilleur de nous-mêmes en
revanche les invite pas ni dans la salle
de bain
en tout cas pas le local à la poubelle
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
certains journalistes ont quand même eu
envie d'aller fouiller dans le local à
poubelle de la police dans un reportage
pour envoyer spécial Stéphane bentura a
montré comment certains policiers
abusaient de leur pouvoir ils portent
parfois pleines pour de soi-disant
outrage contre des citoyens qui se
retrouvent au tribunal alors merci
d'être venu à nouveau en novembre
carrière il a déjà porté plainte une
trentaine de fois
l'affaire d'aujourd'hui est une plainte
pour rébellion une jeune femme qui
contestait les conditions d'une
intervention elle est devenue
complètement hystérique
elle a à me tait beaucoup de gens qui
trouvaient en plein centre-ville dans
l'affaire du jour l'avocat contre
réclamé à la jeune femme 1800 euros de
dommages et intérêts pour les trois
policiers
le journaliste n'a eu aucune difficulté
pour filmer cette séquence dans laquelle
on voit un avocat ils sont clients
policier qui estiment avoir été
injustement invectivé par une citoyenne
mais lorsqu'il a voulu tourner dans un
commissariat pour voir comment on en
arrivait à cette situation de délit
d'outrage cela a été beaucoup plus
compliqué
on a bloqué assez vite sur l'étape
suivante que je leur demandais qui était
essentielle du commissariat en immersion
avec une brigade pour voir pour voir ces
citoyens qui soi-disant s'énervent à
tout bout de champ contre les policiers
et je leur ai dit plusieurs fois je leur
ai dit vous allez donner une connotation
négative à sur portable par absence de
cette séquence avec les policiers dans
un commissariat
Stéphane benturin n'a pas renoncé et au
bout de plusieurs mois a enfin obtenu
l'autorisation qu'il réclamait Patricia
Touran show elle aussi réalisé un
documentaire qui a déplu à l'institution
pour Canal+ elle a dénoncé les dérives
de la politique du chiffre celle qui
conduit des policiers à multiplier les
contrôles plutôt que de faire un travail
de fond et de prévention
qui arrive on va le dire qui entre
guillemets blancs avec des lunettes
salées Versace Italie en gros sur un
train qui arrive d'Italie quoi
voilà alors que Monsieur type africain
qui arrive avec pas très bien habillé
avec son sac plastique je vous dis en
donne un critères
ce type de témoignage a valu à la
journaliste quelques frictions avec la
préfecture de police pendant 6 mois elle
a été privée d'autorisation pour ses
reportages
suite à la diffusion j'ai eu des mesures
de rétorsion quoi donc pendant un moment
mais il faut le savoir quand on s'occupe
de ces questions de police on sait très
bien qu'à un moment donné si on
racontait ce qui se passe ou les choses
qui fâchent entre guillemets et c'est
quand même notre boulot
de le faire à mon avis bon il faut
savoir que le rubriqueur police va être
tricar entre guillemets blacklisté sur
la liste noire comme un petit moment
qu'on puisse parler de représailles je
pense que le travail qui est fait
ce travail de d'échange je travaille de
communication et repose sur des
relations de confiance
si quelque chose s'est mal passé pendant
pendant un sujet
ça me paraît légitime que on cherche à
faire en sorte que ça ne se reproduise
pas alors ça ne veut pas dire que quand
on va faire une croix sur un journal
c'est qu'on ne le enverra plus pas du
tout
les services de communication du
ministère et de la préfecture de police
ont tenté de faire signer des protocoles
à Stéphane ben Tura et Patricia Touran
show ce document les aurait obligé à
faire visionner leur reportage avant
diffusion officiellement pour des
questions de sécurité les deux
journalistes ont refusé d'obtempérer
aujourd'hui cette question de protocole
section de visionnage avant diffusion
des reportages c'est au cœur de
discussion entre les agences de presse
parce que ils le font partout ils
essayent maintenant d'avoir des droits
de regard préalable là je pense qu'avec
ces protocoles de visionnage qui exigent
que tente d'exiger le service de
communication de la police on est on
tombe sur cette ce problème général
qu'on a de plus en plus dans le monde
d'ailleurs où la com essaye de bouffer
l'info
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
difficile de critiquer la police à la
télévision difficile aussi de rendre
compte du quotidien des commissariats
pas très visuels pas très glamour les
flics qui sont juste des hommes et des
femmes et la réalité y est souvent
ennuyeuse on ne voit pas ses difficultés
du quotidien de la police fois la bonne
et simple raison c'est que ça
n'intéresse pas les médias les médias
veulent montrer du spectaculaire c'est
plus joli de montrer le raid en
entraînement que de montrer une
intervention de police secours j'ai
envie de vous répondre je sais pas si
vous regarderiez un magazine aussi entre
guillemets sexy tournée dans un
commissariat avec un néon un peu blafard
d'essayer de garde à vue avec des
baffles en béton pas très propre et un
carrelage un petit peu un petit peu
amoché un trac syndical dans le couloir
et puis trois voitures un peu éborgner
par
[Musique]
par des manœuvres sur le parking
pas facile de captiver le grand public
avec la vie d'un commissariat
en 2006 France 2 tente l'immersion et
installe trois caméras durant un mois
dans le commissariat de Roubaix
nous sommes retournés sur les lieux du
tournage
[Musique]
parmi les policiers filmés à l'époque
Fabrice brigadier il enquêtait alors sur
le braquage d'un bar tabac
j'ai trouvé très bien ce reportage parce
qu'il montrait vraiment une tranche de
vie de la police à rouba
si tu es ici c'est pas par hasard on va
pas placer quelqu'un en garde à vue pour
s'amuser
donc maintenant tu fais une bêtise ok tu
as tes raisons à toi on peut le
concevoir mais à un moment ou un autre
il faut reconnaître ses bêtises il faut
les assumer tes grands maintenant ok
nous sommes d'accord on faisait
abstraction de la présence de la caméra
donc on a plus aussi c'est ça qui était
aussi intéressant c'est qu'on a plus
travaillé normalement sans aucune
influence sans se sentir [ __ ] sans
qu'on signe particulier donc vraiment
travailler comme d'habitude on les
oublie un peu quoi et à mon avis le
rendu est beaucoup plus positif si les
gens restent longtemps
[Musique]
Marie Dominique travaille toujours à la
brigade des mineurs elitera de
l'histoire lourde d'enfants battus et
d'inceste
dans le reportage de France 2 elle était
filmée lors d'une garde à vue avec une
mère de famille qui avait maltraité ses
enfants
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
franchement non alors
de confronter ta gamine avec toi je
t'oblige
tu te rends compte un peu dans la tête
de cette gamine ça va faire quoi
pourquoi j'acceptais parce que pour que
pour que on puisse voir ce qu'on fait
comme comme travail est-ce que la
matière contrainte
pas comme dans les séries télé ou voilà
quoi ou on raconte des conneries de A à
Z et puis voir qu'il y a des il y a des
gosses qui sont malheureux il y a des
gosses qui sont
montrés
montrer quelques la police elle fait
qu'elle fait j'espère un bon travail et
qu'elle peut sortir de de de cette
misère tous ces gosses qui sont là c'est
pour ça que j'ai choisi mon boulot moi
et moi je voulais c'est pour ça que je
leur ai dit moi il faut il faut filmer
la vérité il faut pas aux oliviers il
faut pas couper c'est la vérité pure et
dure voilà c'est ça notre métier alors
je me suis rendu compte
de ma violence parce qu'il pleurait le
reportage après quand on a quand on l'a
vu quoi c'est ben oui ça va se refléter
la vérité quoi c'était ça c'était map
c'était la police que je vis tous les
jours quoi et mes collègues également
voilà c'est tout
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les flics aiment la télé quand elle ne
les maltraite pas la télé aime les flics
même si elle les fantasmes souvent unis
par les liens d'un mariage d'amour et
d'intérêt le couple Médiapolis a donc un
bel avenir
chacun veut exister chacun veut montrer
qu'il est qu'il est efficace compétent
il faut être dans l'image et puis il
faut se faire connaître quoi si on n'est
pas connu on n'existe pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]